[Music]
was actually from here he went back to
first of all given to Bella for many
years then she went to Greece and in the
last five years is a syncopal University
of Technology and design Checotah Eric
is a professor of energy director center
and so on so thank you well okay so I
cannot express how happy and how honored
I am and how emotional I am to be here
today and I said to myself have to
prepare what to say but then I said I
know I cannot do it because I felt that
I would like to just speak out of the
spur of the moment okay so not for the
technical talk
I mean thinking about about draw I can
think of a few things the first thing is
that I'm very privileged that the most
important is that we are also very good
friends and I love John Deere Lee is one
of the sweetest people and I really feel
that if I need something wrong with
helping I said before many other people
so that's the first thing the second
thing is that probably I'm very
privileged also because I have been a
quarter of them in many papers and that
made me experience his
his qualities and his his genius type of
capability okay I have to admit Jean is
ahead of me had always been and she
taught me a lot of things when we work
together and I can tell you if you work
with wrong you really learn okay and he
goes back to the simplest basic
principles
everything is derived from scratch the
essential nothing more and of course I
have now to give also and honored to
provide because we are all key students
and I think this kind of attitude right
we copied from the big teacher right and
I'm very sorry I was not when probably
retired here in the enduring keys
ceremony to thank him also for that but
I think all your students inherited
please stop okay of course we are not
all at that level too good but we always
try to copy that for the good over the
world because once you have been touched
by that attitude you cannot become an
entrepreneur you cannot cheat you cannot
fight you cannot be greedy and then you
you keep always been you know a good
honest scientist which it used to be
like the style in the 80s and the 90s
but then I think today we all have to
sell things and we have to compete with
things and we have to really sell things
we don't really care for and anyway I
think most of us in this room come from
the old good times the world with times
of maths entering the labs or Berkeley
without projects and it was it was a it
was really something that can never
happen again and we all share that and
we are very lucky to be in this world
so those are the two things I would like
to mention of course I have many more
but I saved them for dinner okay let's
go back to that thing here which is not
interesting right but I think what is
interesting is that both myself and
Antonis have been in close collaboration
John so I as Nico said we overlapped at
Berkeley and John was the first one who
read my thesis was it in my situation
commenting right probably and of course
he helped me a lot and then Antonius was
my student on Crete and of course where
is the next place go to the to the
motherland here right with all the big
father the the brother and all that so
he came here and we continued a
tradition and so I'm very happy today
that I will give this talk that this
jointly was on Tony and Tony prepared
the slides and then Tony's actually did
the hard work that I would present the
things we did that I did in my life
motivated actually all the work on
pricing and network anomic I started of
course probably initially even my thesis
we had a game theory issue about sharing
resources with people did not care about
Pareto and economics but the first time
we did economics pathos of food wrong
and he had this idea in a small project
we had with NATO he came to Crete 1992
and at that time he had this idea of
putting economics into and pricing into
into the everything as we are doing
together right so yeah so everything
came from here right so I told that anti
all right so let me explain here so
let me now go to the first important
slide all right so this is a slide that
shows Zhang and Richard Weber and this
guy here who's this guy
I'm pretty sure you can tell Sean
because Roy is the same did not change
much right yeah so I think that was me
at the time right and I just want to say
that though always look the segment is
old because she's very very cool
she's very useful he doesn't get
irritated he's happy he's deeply happy
that's why he never ages okay so look at
the difference right I mean this and
this this and that
okay perhaps he Lou young okay so let's
continue with a little bit more
technical stuff so this is the title and
the work we will present today is
actually goes back to the whole style of
work where I think the model is
interesting the concepts are interesting
the questions are interesting and you
can even get some interesting way I mean
are interesting answers with not by
using very heavy machinery and large
deviations and and food limits and all
that okay so it's simple but I think is
very interesting in terms of the
questions we posed and all this area of
trying too much supply and demand in
systems of mobility I think is a great
place for new problems and for for for
discovering new problems so I think what
I would like you to take from this
discussion is the type of problems and
what kind of questions we are asking
so we will talk a little bit about
ride-sharing and a model of passenger
queuing issues about stability and the
question on how to incentivize ways that
drivers can match the demand because
many people looked at the problem on how
to solve some large linear programs or
how to optimum optimally control the
drivers but drivers are not cannot be
centrally controlled drivers are having
their own incentives are moving around
so an interesting question is how can
you achieve stable systems so stability
is a type of optimality we can send it
so this is I think the key idea here and
the questions that any questions you
have to go to Antonis of course right
so you know about right hailing I don't
have to say anything about that but it
has really disrupted transportation
industry right and the key issue is that
there is a platform so what's the
difference between right healing and tax
we had taxes for millions of years right
so what is new now at Haley
well in my opinion - what is new is the
fact we have a platform that has
centralized information and can optimize
the way the thing works and you have
real-time and online ways that people
can share information and do things in
that sense right you can have you have a
real-time you can have information about
incentives and drivers can be more
sophisticated right so drivers can
really move around in a selfish way but
they can really optimize you know their
own profit before that it was more
instinctive kind of driving how could
you drive now you could be driving
around by consent so you know how it
works so you have an arrival of
customers that want rides you have cars
that drive around and the key question
is how to merge the plan demand and that
was the same with the taxi case but
what's new here is the fact that those
cars I mean their main differences okay
one difference is that those cars that
the number of cars could change
according to demand and according to the
incentive you give interlock so there
are many times Gate right in the wrong
time scale is how many cars you have
available in the shorter time scales how
you match the scarce and there are many
distinct questions now because you have
those platforms you can have dynamic
pricing and you can do even more
interesting things you could cluster
many people in the same car and that
probably does the future right if you
don't share then congestion will say the
same one can prove that if you do
sharing then there is a hope that
congestion can be greatly reduced and
refining economy can be useful but if
there is no sharing there's no sharing
economy right I mean it's and so there
are many do some questions and the way I
mean one of the basic
is how those cars move around where
they're free right and that's what I've
like motivated so there are many
interesting object different algorithms
and every player has a different
objective so the passengers want to get
a ride and the drivers want to maximize
profits they have to decide to become
members of the platform they want to
decide to accept a ride or not or
keeping free and the platform objectives
are clearly maximize profits and
throughput it's not social well for
maximization this profit maximization
right so sharing economy is not for for
for the society releases for profit
stuff and there are many distinct
questions like driver user matchings
driver compensation and passenger fees
how do we compute the amount of money we
give to drivers and passengers and of
course I mean how do you prove that I
mean how do you compute those numbers
optimally and the big question is should
they be dynamic or static so what we
gain by dynamic stuff versus static
stuff right that's a question that I
don't think has been answered adequately
so in this talk actually at the end we
will show that a max weight kind of
policy like Jordan talked about if you
apply with prices basically so you
increase the price when the the pressure
is higher right then that can stabilize
the system and get get you all of the
stable rigid right so you can actually
so you can explain that search pricing
that uber does has an interpretation of
much weight I think that's an
interesting takeaway for this community
I'm not gonna go into too much about the
existing work but just to give you an
idea there is there are so many
different aspects in this problem that
different people looked at different
aspects so there have been questions
about how to match optimally supply and
demand so how do you model demand so
customers arrive do they kill they don't
use right so many people you know most
of the work has been without kills
people come and if there is something
you can match them they stay otherwise
they go right so it's always stable but
it's not optimal right the next question
is how do you move drivers around so
that you can do better match and people
can solve this using a centralized
optimization problem and but tooth out
using incentives so it's it's it's not
obvious how you can incentivize
something that is optimal and something
that that solves an automation problem
right so how you do that and other
people looked at things in the long term
equitable so you choose prices which
induce eventually many drivers to be
able to become members of the platform
and eventually to get the better revenue
but this kind of long-term stuff might
not be appropriate when you want to
control your cars within the next hour
where you have a certain pattern of
demand right so again time scales are
very important and if you look at
different times can you get different
models that's all a word I said so there
cannot be a unique model to cut through
right healing and all of them tell us
something right but it's very hard to
put them together of course yeah as
usually so I mean there's it's a very
rich I think topic so our our work has
been actually on smaller time scales
where we assume a fixed number of
drivers and the question is how do you
move them around right and we care for
stability we want to be able to much
exactly the demand in terms of rates to
be
and and there is cute people don't go
away if they are not sure so I think
it's a good idea to use a toy example to
illustrate some of the questions right
so a circle represents a location so
let's break our geography to location so
that we here we have three locations one
two three and let's assume that people
can move between adjacent locations
right so that's how people move and you
get arrivals of customers that so that's
demand that arrived in location one and
what good location too so that's lambda
1 and lambda 3 from 3 to 2 right okay
and how do those guys go back well if
you if you have cars that will be
serving those customers every car that
goes here somehow must go back here in
order to just pick up customers so if
you would like to have a stable system
necessarily you need at least a flow of
cars or any lambda 1 gone that way so
now the red thing of the red as being
drivers right as being cars which are
busy customers they should much lambda1
and the blue are the free ones freeze if
I don't carry a customer they have
become I must be getting that ice at
least so the first question is what is
the stability condition stability
condition in terms of how many cars I
need what's the minimum number of
drivers and that's one of the
fundamental question we asked in our
research is how can I make a system
stable with the minimum number of cars
so in that case what's the minimum
number of cars okay clearly let's say
that's the time it takes for every
transition from region to region is a
one unit of time in that case you are
going to have lambda1 cars on that per
unit of time on this path lambda one
cars here so we are going to have to
lambda one cars on that part of the
network to lambda three cars there so
you need at least a number of drivers D
to be more than that right okay
I think about it what is the issue here
when a driver is in state two so let's
say lambda 3 is twice lambda 1 so in
that case I want with twice a bigger
rate of drivers going that way than
going that way but the current comes
here and is free
why should we pick with bigger
probability to go to 3 than to do right
and 1 that's the question so for example
if I could control them completely to do
that then I only need D right but let's
say a driver here flips a coin to go
randomly left or right in that case in
order to get enough people here I'm
gonna get so anyway in order to get
enough people here I have to get more
dragon right so clearly that condition
cannot hold right I need a big goodie to
stabilize the system right and the
question is what is this
so if I have drivers with a fixed
mobility pattern for example they you
know they drive according to historical
data or something what's the minimum D
the next question is how can I enforce
the optimal mobility patterns for the
free driver so how can I get them lambda
3 number one and so that's the question
okay sorry for that slide is too too
heavy
Antoni okay so I'm joking right so let's
say now let's see it that way so let's
say we have the drivers total and I
throw them in this network and let's say
the partition themselves into D 1 and D
3 so D 1 plus D 3 is equal to D right
what's going to happen in those loops
well let's take this loop here I have D
three drivers total half of them were
going be going that way cattle would be
going that way
right so let's say for the moment that D
3 over 2 is less than the total rate
right so all of them get full and they
go like this the rest of them will will
be here right so if if D 3 over 2 is
less than lambda 3 all those cars are
full and all of them go like this
if
3 over 2 is bigger than lambda 3 then I
get lambda 3 here because they cannot
leave empty lambda 3 going back and the
rest of them would be going here
so in fewers I can write I can find this
explicitly and how will this D 1 and D 3
be actually configured well they should
get the same average revenue right if a
driver goes and does that or should be
the SEC right so we expect in the
equilibria that thing to be like that
and then I can write this kind of
equation that relates D 1 and D 3 and
also have that the sum who should be
equal to D and that gives me unique
solution so if I look at the Wardrobe
kind of equilibrium with with this kind
of sorry so I forgot to tell you I use a
sorry word and that's the magical thing
so let's say I use rewards right I
cannot completely compute as a function
of D 1 and D 3 the average reward of a
driver here another driver here and I
this would be equal in equilibrium and
that's the equation and trivial right
and you can get it equal to D and you
can find the 100 be free for any value
of D so what's the question of think of
R 1 and R 3 as controls and I want to
move our 1 and R 3 so that basically the
number of drivers going here and here
cover lambda 1 and lambda 3 right so
that's what I want to do so the question
is under what condition can I control
the flows of the three of the of the
free drivers actually so that I can
cover my demand that we have so I want
to cover my lambdas by arrivals of the
customers
so what domina question is if I have a
stable system can I find a set of
rewards which will also induce a stable
routing right of the drivers and this is
the type of questions we are we're after
and the previous question that we said
before is that if free drivers have a
fixed mobility pattern what is the
minimum number of drivers hang it right
so these kind of questions are the
question we ask we assume the drivers
are rational optimizers which means that
they can compute average rewards I can
solve them the piece and all that which
is not of course it's not it's not it's
not I think it's it's a bit far-fetched
but always what we solve in theory is
you know a contract question that that
says if things were done really well I
mean correctly then how things would be
a but you can imagine that drivers will
have ups which run for their own benefit
and the drivers share information about
revenue they get in different routes and
they could actually create a very nice
incentive system they use in order to
drive and get more money so drivers so
it's not the platform that tells you
that one could tell you the wrong thing
but the driver is now smart right that's
the idea
how much time I have
five minutes so let me give you some
nice five minutes all right so what let
me go about the model and then I tell
you about the results right I think the
model is interesting and you should
understand the model and so we have a
fixed number of drivers so it's a closed
system and there there are regions right
everything okay and there's a continuous
time semi Markov process that was
mobility so how so a driver that enters
our region becomes busy with some
probability theta sub I now we will see
how this is constructed all states free
now if you are busy where the transition
X is chosen by your customer and it's
given by some probability that is
exogenous if you are free you choose
that to some other probability that
either could be fixed by some historical
reasons or can be the result of solving
an optimization problem and every
transition take some random exponential
time when you enter the new region if
you're busy you become free and again
you have to do the same right to suffer
bibbidi you become busy and you keep
going like that so it is like a closed
network of servers which are moving
around so now it's not customers that
move around networks its service moving
around networks okay so it's a it's a
it's a it's a very interesting model I
think that Antonis what about this idea
of the service moving around and I think
that's a beautiful idea for some photo
and that's these are the policy process
if I give you this information I can
decouple the drivers from the customers
because I can tell you how a driver move
around so every driver is like it does
not care for the other drivers okay and
that's that's a key fit and the queuing
model is that people come and wait in
queues and there's a queue length that
we take into account then you take
customers from the twos so let's see
what kind of policy processes we have so
first of all you could have a set of an
arbitrary policy process which means and
driver that arrives in this region could
decide not to get busy or could decide
to be busy or it can do anything it was
at any point in time you know on a
dynamic way or end or even he could pick
up additional customer and that's the
new thing so the platform could tell you
I'll give you a virtual customer you get
money from me because I want you to go
where this customer would go so it
controls my tool there is the set of
static policies which means with a
certain probability fixed probability
people get busy there is the set of
policies which do not elaborate your
customer would say you cannot live busy
from that region unless there is a
customer and there is a third one which
is super conserving that says that if
there is a customer you have to get busy
so there is lots of policies here that's
the most general one where people can
drive a scram move around in arbitrary
way and this is those are more
restricted ones and more practical ones
and optimization I mean the optimality
we try to solve is about stability rate
stability right so I want to be able in
the long run to get the rates of arrival
simple to the rates of busy drivers
and the question we ask is what is the
stability region if you allow any kind
of policy the largest one what happens
if you have static points which means a
driver goes to a region has a guarantee
with a probability that she's gonna get
busy okay and if there's nobody there
perhaps she gets a virtual customer from
the platform right so I guarantee this
kind of probability of getting a
customer the driver and that's the case
of having no built roster I do I cannot
do that he always have to get the
customer and this is the case that if
there is a customer there he cannot be
free and continue but he has to get it
and so this is the type of questions we
have and of course there is a parallel
thing how do you move freely I mean
there you can solve the question you can
ask the stability condition if drivers
have a fixed way they move when they are
free or if you can even control that so
there are two cases so let me just go to
the to the to the to the key results so
what are the key results well I don't I
don't think I have time to do that but I
can just summarize them right so let me
summarize those those theories are so
the key results let me go here is I have
basically the biggest stability reason
that we get overall policies it's
strictly bigger than so if you allow me
virtual service it's strictly bigger
than if you force me to always carry
customers right and can be strictly
bigger right and if I can control your
your your your your trip by incentives
then actually all those collapse to the
same one and I can incentivize the
biggest possible set we can get the are
by solving some optimization problems
that there are large multipliers of a
dual and all that and you can actually
control how
we'll be moving around so that if
something stabilizable with a number of
drivers then I can get it
well this is the type of okay there are
many other results we have but I don't
think I have time but so that's the idea
the idea is that you have this model of
surface moving around and you have these
different policies of picking customers
and you cannot have interesting
constraints on well Stanley can become
busy or not and then you can ask those
questions about matching supply and
demand and incentives the last thing I'd
like to talk about is that if I if I
make my prices to be proportional to the
queues of customers in the different
region then that system automatically
achieves the biggest stable region so
this type of search pricing is optimal
in terms of stability and you don't have
to compute anything because otherwise
the optimal static prices you have to
compute you have to have all those
parameters of the system the arrival
rates the things which of course they
don't make sense right well all they do
make sense in some kind of approximate
way but if you want to have a robust
system then a dynamic pricing is works
very well and it also works much better
for delays if you look at delays the
same points which are stable with the
same number of servers
max we give you lower average delay okay
so it's it's quite interesting so I
stopped here and my last leg
why so many slides underneath okay Peter
that's my slide okay so I say good luck
for the new life you talk about delay in
the last slide Google search price was
this life information so at this time in
this location is this and people try to
go there but by the time they arrive the
situation change and people will just
change search locations and never get I
think our model understands that problem
right and don't say it solves it because
if you use the cube lengths as prices
right or proxies for prices then you
assume that the drivers solve an MDP
right which I which assumes that those
those prices would be there forever so
you cannot predict the evolution of the
queues in in your in your optimization
right so far we cannot do that all right
so you take this information about the
prices now and you look at your optimal
mobility based on those prices but this
is not myopic this is a long-term thing
so if these are very long and change
slowly yes it's true but if queues are
not long and chase fast so fast
comparing to the length of the trick
right if it takes you one minute to get
there there there is no problem but if
it takes you like half an hour and by
half an hour prices are very different
and clearly you're so you know there are
ideas on how to model that but so you
like to do some things there but that's
a big data that's a good question
that's a very good question thank
okay
[Applause]